Earlier today,
I wrote my husband a note
asking him to surprise me with dinner reservations,
and he did! He asked a
few New York locals what their favorite spots were
and then picked one,
made a reservation,
and here we are at the Monkey Bar.
I loved how cozy the atmosphere was.
If there's mocktails on the menu,
we get the mocktails.
I didn't like the one I ordered,
so lucky traded me
even though he didn't like mine either,
but his was really good.
We got some artichoke dip and vodka pasta for starters.
Vodka pasta was very mediocre.
Make better vodka pasta
so I wasn't impressed.
But lucky ended up finishing off the pasta and the dip
because I limited myself to only eating a little bit
cause I knew I wouldn't be able to have my main
if I had more.
We both got steaks
and then I got some creamy mushrooms and buttery
garlic mashed potatoes with it
while he got some French fries with his.
My favorite thing were the mushrooms.
They were so good
with the steak key.
Having steak with ketchup felt criminal,
but it was a lot better than it looked.
I was in a food coma at this point
and I couldn't finish my food,
so lucky had the rest.
I still needed something sweet
so we got some ice cream and headed back to the hotel.